yesterday you know not the most glorious
day in Twitter's 20-month 20 months as a
public company let's talk a little bit
about the earnings what went wrong
particularly from a revenue standpoint
why why was there softness that seem to
surprise Wall Street well I think we
have a great advertising business and as
we said on the call we had a slight
missed due to direct response ads and by
the way define that because maybe some
of you sure no direct response ads as
opposed to a brand a brand advertising
just generally speaking a brand
advertisement is I'm looking to reach
this many people with this kind of
message whereas a direct response that
is more of a suit yeah and a direct
response at is more I want to achieve
this kind of objective it might be I
want my app downloaded it might be I
want people to click on my website link
and feel fill out a form a lead gen etc
so our direct business didn't scale as
fast as we thought it would based on
that what we'd seen in the over the last
year of growth and that's what we're
working on is that a factor of bringing
new advertisers out of the platform or
getting the advertisers that are playing
with your correct response tools to
stick around and to see an roi I think
it's really a combination of a couple
different things as a demand as Anthony
said on the call generally speaking for
direct response ads and then some but I
wouldn't I wouldn't overemphasize this
some of it was due to moving some of our
direct response advertisers from what
you might consider a cpe pricing cost
per engagement where the advertiser pays
for any engagement with a tweet whether
it's a click or a favorite or retweet
etc to what we call CPX pricing cost per
objective where I really only want to
pay for when people click on my link and
come much higher bar so it's a much
higher bar it's a much better marketing
funnel for that advertiser so the ROI
assumedly is driven up of course you
want to see the bids grow over time as
they start to get better our ROI and
that's what we hope will happen